[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice you can use in your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about
cynicism as a philosophy of life and
this is a word that a lot of people
throw around it's
it's got a lot of different meanings to
it if you know dan when i say you're
such a cynic what's the first thing that
comes to mind for you
i'm usually like pessimistic
okay
yeah that or like maybe a little bit
nihilistic
yeah you know and we'll talk about what
these terms mean i i was actually as we
were getting ready for the show thinking
about you know there's a song i've heard
somewhere that talks about this and i
realize that it's a stick song uh
fooling yourself and it starts out the
very first line is you see the world
through your cynical
eyes you're a troubled young man i can
tell of course when they saying that you
know everybody who was a young man at
the time is now an old man just like the
band is and the the line for the chorus
goes you're fooling yourself if you
don't believe it you're kidding yourself
if you don't believe it what what are
they supposed to believe
well you know the earlier verses you've
got it all in the palm of your hand but
your hands wet with sweat and your head
needs a rest so life it kind of sucks
you know even though it doesn't really
suck and i think that's what a lot of
people think of
as cynicism today right
yeah it's a
i'll just kind of a general
i feel like everyone goes through a
little bit of that like maybe in their
early 20s or something when you go from
like you you get out of your house and
all these things that sound so easy and
straightforward and kind of black and
white they start to become more and more
gray yeah like oh this this nice ordered
world that we thought we had is not as
easy to put into little boxes yeah
things are way more complicated and
there's always like a form that has to
be filled out or you should have paid
this deposit or things like that i don't
know that everybody goes through that
though i mean i've run into people who
were like when i was in college who were
in their
20s and they were still very
very naive and pollyannaish and
everything is wonderful they're they're
clearly not cynics right
no so but doesn't mean that they won't
be at some point in time yeah we should
say for our listeners too that we're not
advocating that kind of cynicism we are
going to talk a little bit about it
because it's part of the culture but
we're we're proposing that you think
about an
earlier conception of cynicism which i
don't have any problem calling in some
respects more authentic or
closer to the source because i mean
that's where the word got its coinage
right from the ancient cynics
so
you know but we should start by talking
about what cynicism means today which is
you know kind of a generalized
mistrust or distrust of other people and
their motivations or organizations or
politics or
pick whatever you know whatever you want
sort of like the guy who said whatever
you got i'm against it you know
um and
i think that one of the key parts of it
is this like things can't be as good as
you're making them out to be i'm gonna
peel back the mask and reveal
the the true state of things which is
that you know everybody's everybody's
bad deep inside including myself and
that's why i get to say it because i'm
not being a hypocrite you know i think
that's the way that we understand cynics
today right
okay holden
sorry obviously a holden caught built
from catching the rye as a reference
there and but for those who didn't get
assigned that back in high school and go
through their own everybody's a phony
phase
right
um but i'm the phoniest of them all
uh well that's interesting
at the risk of taking a digression is
there
you know if you're if you're going to be
a phony or you're going to be cynical
about stuff is it better to be worse off
than everybody else if you're going to
be criticizing them because then you can
say i really understand
this badness
well this kind of to bring us back to
ancient philosophy sounds a lot like
our good friend
um
teacher of plato socrates who okay says
um uh the only thing i know is that i
know nothing so he's going out and
asking all these people what do you
believe uh or what what are the how do
you define virtue how do you find
goodness and all these things and and
he's just saying like well you know
i can't define it you are the one that
says you can define it so you obviously
have to know but then finds all these
holes in it so this is kind of a very
similar digression that like
only because i'm the phony can i
actually see the phoniness and all the
other people around you yeah and to come
back to cynics if if you're a modern-day
cynic
you can say well i know exactly what
sort of thing you're going to get up to
because i would be doing the same thing
myself maybe i'm too old or you know i
don't have the resources but i i would
certainly be a bad guy
just like i know that you're a bad guy
yeah and
it's in part it's like it's
counterproductive because there are
people that actually do want to make
things better but if you are constantly
um you know opposing them criticizing
them yeah
and saying like oh you can't actually
have any good intentions that you know
everyone's just out there to like get
one over on everyone else um then
there there's nothing that's going to
actually help bring us to
this this better world or this the seal
any sort of progress you know and
progress is impossible yeah and it risks
a self-fulfilling prophecy right if you
treat people
as if they're going to lie cheat and
steal
some of them at least are going to be
like well you're already treating me
that way so i may as well behave that
way
um if you give me the chance you know
and and so you mentioned
pessimism and nihilism
i i think that this kind of conception
of cynicism you're right it is aligned
with those and also with what we can
call misanthropy so we probably need to
say for the viewers what what these
actually are
yeah so like a pessimism here is you
know a general lack of hope i believe
that bad things will happen and that
things will just get worse in general
and nihilism is the belief that there is
no meaning into our lives no inherent
meaning and that is pointless for us to
look for it
um and and then
misanthropy is the disliking of
humankind and avoiding human society in
general
yeah so
those are all bad things and there are a
lot of people like that but they're
usually pretty miserable
i i think there's some people who are
kind of attached to those
they wouldn't want to give them up even
though they're making them unhappy
but this doesn't have to be the kind of
cynicism that we're
advocating or looking at or delving into
this is only one modern contemporary use
of the term
but there's a lot more to cynicism than
that and i think that cynicism is is
like a lot of other
words we've mentioned this in previous
shows epicureanism doesn't mean stuffing
your face like a pig an epicurean would
actually be very
uh measured in their
intake of pleasant things um stoics
aren't unemotional they you know there
are good emotions in stoicism and i
think the same thing happened with
cynicism somewhere down the line where
um
what the ancient cynics stood for
became something quite different than
what contemporary cynics
if they if there is anything they stand
for that's it maybe it's purely negative
right
right it's very uh history's version of
the game of telephone
uh oh one person yeah you gotta explain
that for some of our listeners because
okay so what's the game of the game of
telephone is uh you um one person is
told a thing at the very beginning of a
line and they have to
then uh in turn
whisper that into the ear of the next
person in line and that person then has
to repeat this over and over until you
get to the end and the the hope is well
i don't know what the hope is exactly
the game is to see if you can actually
get the information correctly passed
from the first to the last person and
this also requires a modicum of trust
that the people aren't going to just for
the fun of it
change them and so like you know part of
it is um you you have uh competing
schools and and sometimes there's
uh someone from a competing schools that
will uh straw man the other and this
will give us a bad conception of what
these other schools actually are and
then someone comes down and reads this
and was like i don't have any other
books that are talking about this um so
this must be the true version of this
thing and just copies that that becomes
the new definition over and over you
know the people who write popular
literature
in in like philosophy or culture in
general are the worst for that like
i've found so many
fake quotes on the internet because i've
gotten now like into trying to to round
them up and say no this is not by
epictetus this is not by aristotle
so many of them come from will durant's
the story of philosophy which is still
super super popular you go to any
bookstore and you go to the philosophy
section and there it is even though you
know durant died a long time ago
and durant will give you his takes on
people and sometimes they're accurate
and sometimes they're not you know and
then somebody will take they'll harvest
something out of his book and they'll
present it as if it this is what
aristotle said or this is what epictetus
said even though it's not even
close and i think i think that's that's
part of what has happened with with
cynicism over the
centuries a great example of this is
nietzsche uh who actually knew ancient
philosophy quite well he was a
philologist he he writes in beyond good
and evil he talks about i mean so-called
cynics those who simply recognize the
animal the commonplace and the rule in
themselves and at the same time have so
much spirituality and ticklishness as to
make them talk of themselves and they're
like before witnesses sometimes they
wallow even in books as on their own
dunghill cynicism is now here's this is
great cynicism is the only form
in which base souls approach what is
called honesty and the higher man must
open his ears to all the coarser finer
cynicism and congratulate himself when
the clown becomes shameless right before
him or the scientific sadder speaks out
so he's presenting cynicism as this like
you know it's something that that
low-class people do or low-class
intellects engage in and they they
wallow
uh
as on their own dunghill
uh you know a heap of crap
that's what a dung hill is
and so that's what that's what he takes
cynicism to actually mean you know
yeah
and
because he brought that up like it it
also like just
before we like fully step into this
ancient cynicism there are certain
things in the
in the three transformations of the
spirit when he talks about
the process of becoming the being the
cow the one that just takes on all the
burdens that's heart
taken uh that are given to us and then
you know the progression to becoming the
lion which is to try to
slay the dragon of thou shalt um
at least in this portion of it this is
actually very similar to some things
that we're going to be talking about
yeah
in the cynicism that uh in the you know
rejecting of social conventions which
in the way that is spoken in zarathustra
you could absolutely call thou shalt
thou shalt you know um wear clothing
thou shalt like use a bowl to drink from
the uh the river thou shalt uh live in a
house thou shalt not you know on
masturbate in the marketplace
there you go
um
and and so it's interesting um
his disdain for it but also
on his
putting forward some of the ideas that
the cynics also came to well maybe
that's a contrast between like again the
modern cynic and the ancient cynic you
know
um somebody else who i thought we would
you know maybe bring up is uh somebody
who's still alive
uh
slaughter dick who wrote a critique of
cynical reason years and years and years
ago
and he calls modern cynics borderline
melancholics who can keep their symptoms
of depression under control
and yet retain the ability to work
whatever might happen and he says indeed
this is the essential point in modern
cynicism the ability of its bearers to
work in spite of anything that might
happen and so you get the idea that with
some of the people theorizing about
cynicism today they view it as something
that's going to inevitably arise within
a late capitalist economy where you know
a lot of things are screwed up and
things aren't what they pretend to be i
mean think about the prevalence of
advertising and marketing everywhere and
you know cynicism is in part about
tearing down the veils of things and
showing them what they they are
showing them as what they are and um
at the same time nothing changes by
being a modern cynic
you're just kind of
sniping at people but it doesn't produce
any significant change whereas the
ancient cynics boy it was about changing
who you were in
really all across the board right
yeah although there is definitely a on
when we're talking about ancient we're
really talking about like the
hellenistic cynics and we'll just get
into them momentarily but even by the
roman era the cynic name had gotten a
tinge of us to add it upon it i think
that's in part because there were people
who took advantage of
the uh the philosophy or the way of life
to
kind of do their own dirty little thing
and you know you could uh wander around
and beg and
yell mean things at people and call
yourself a cynic and get away with it
there's there's things like that today
right
but the thing is that they
they were using it as a i don't know a
guy's but not actually walking the walk
right cynic and so it already began to
tarnish because there are people that
took it up as this uh
thing that they could use to uh dismiss
any sort of
criticism of them it's like oh
why are you being such a you know an
[ __ ] or why are you being busy right
yeah well i'm just acidic and like you
know and that was their defense yeah
i mean you could say that it was kind of
a shield in a way calling yourself a
cynic as opposed to saying yeah i'm just
a lazy guy who doesn't like to do stuff
and like i don't bathe and it's you know
i wander around from place to place
because i i'm offensive to people
i mean there's there's a lot of people
like that today who
claim that they're like social critics
but they're just jerks too you know
yeah
so uh so let's let's get into the actual
classics here
yeah so you know it's a philosophical
school there's a lot of important
philosophical schools that arise as um
you know we're saying in the hellenistic
that means like later than the the early
hellenic period which would include
plato and aristotle we're talking about
the time when the greek city-states are
basically
losing their freedom and under the the
uh reign of at first the macedonians and
then you know successor states and
eventually the romans take all all of
that over
and
you know like a lot of the philosophies
it develops in athens and
there's there's actually some debate
among contemporary scholars about
whether it really was a coherent school
that was
that had a lineage from socrates himself
going through this guy antisthenes who
i'm a big fan of and then to diogenes
and then you know from one teacher to
another that that might actually be made
up it might have been something that the
stoics kind of made up so that it gave
them a lineage
but i i don't know i i think that it
personally i i tend to think that
antisthenes really was
a
cynic and he might have you know taught
diogenes
um and
you know he's the guy that the school
traditionally gets started with and then
there's a succession of uh teachers and
then a whole bunch of other people who
glom onto it
and they also like a lot of
schools like to read backwards and say
oh by the way you know before the school
was actually started there were other
people who who were living the life this
this scythian
anacarsus
they thought of hercules as being like a
typical cynic why because he wanders
around you know writing wrongs and you
know he he's basically just got a club
and a lion you know skin he's
and he's a tough guy you know
um
diogenes laertes has this beautiful
passage
when he's talking about the cynics and
he says antisthenes gave the impulse
to the
indifference of diogenes the apothea
meaning not being moved by passions
the
continents or self-control of krates
who's who's also a cynic the
encretius
being able to control yourself and then
the hardy hood of zeno who's the founder
of the stoics
the carterias the endurance and then he
says something really interesting laying
the foundations of their state and the
word that's translated their estate
is actually the word politea which means
like political community
so
they're being viewed as if they're part
of not just a lineage not just a way of
life but but a community
and and i think there's something
kind of attractive to that you know this
idea that you and i if we practice this
we could be
not just like successors to antisthenes
or diogenes but we could be part of like
a commonwealth that
includes you and me and anybody else who
wants to be like that you know yeah
yeah too fine communion and well
they are also a little bit common
politicism
cosmopolitan here
yeah
have a feeling of being part of a
politic
uh body that is of everyone
um but i also wanted to add like you
know these are
once again another school as uh
in philosophy as a way of life this is
kind of one of the basic ideas of what
we talk about in this particular
uh
radio show that's you know we're looking
for practical philosophy and they this
school as well as the other um ancient
hellenistic schools are all looking for
what does it mean to have a good life
and a lot of them are looking for what
is this you know uh eudaimonic what
results in this eudaimonic and apathetic
um life that you know i guess not all of
them are are looking for on
uh the the lack of negative passions um
but at least every one of these are
looking for the eudaimonic life and they
yeah
a very similar position as a number of
the other ones they are virtue
school-based and virtue um just like you
will see in
the uh aristotelians as well as the
soaks the stoics and so we'll go a
little bit more to that i'll say too
that even the epicureans and they're
they're kind of around the same time you
know
um epicurus is arriving on the scene
after
aristotle so you could say like he's
probably a contemporary of of krates the
the third main cynic guy
um you know they they seem to have
thought that the virtues mattered they
just had a different reason for valuing
them
they even thought friendship was a
really important thing and you know all
the ancient schools seem to value
friendship as well
um
so that's yeah
that's a good point that there's a lot
of overlap the motivations are somewhat
different though i i would that's that's
probably the key thing
so
i did want to mention you know for those
of you who and we're going to give you
another reading reading recommendation
later on of a really great book at the
end but where do we learn about these
people so all of these
ancient cynics they actually wrote books
themselves and we know this because we
have listings of these books that we no
longer have but we also we know not just
from this guy diogenes laertes
um who was not a great philosopher but
was a decent historian we know from
other people in ancient times who said
well i read these books and that here's
what they said and and that's you know
they were good or they were bad
but there's a lot of other
interesting sources besides diogenes
xenophon the student of socrates who is
also a military commander wrote a
symposium in which antisthenes is one of
the
characters and gives a speech
and tells us about his way of life
lucian of samasota who i'm a big fan of
because he's a funny funny writer he's
actually a satirist
a lot of times he's poking fun not just
at the cynics but all the other
branches of philosophy and he has in
mind the j the jerk cydics right the
jackasses who you just talked about a
little bit but he also has a dialogue
called the cynic
and he lets the cynic a good cynic say
his piece in it and like present the
philosophy and there was a guy
apparently damon axe who was a cynic
and lucian wrote a life of demon acts in
which we learn a bit more about him
epictetus the great stoic philosopher
liked the cynics quite a bit he talks
about diogenes almost as much as he does
socrates and he has an entire chapter
of his discourses and not a short
chapter a long chapter uh which is about
the cynic way of life and he's like yeah
you know it's not for everybody but if
you can pull it off um
go ahead and be a cynic
uh that's the shortcut to virtue yeah
the royal road sometimes they they they
translate it as you know meaning like
it's the direct route rather than
what we
you know rum dumbs ordinary people have
to do it right
and then there's there's deo chrysostom
um he writes a whole bunch of orations
he he was a guy who had kind of a hard
luck life and wound up like being
banished and wanders around but does a
lot of writing and diogenes is one of
the guys who he
writes about a lot and maybe the stories
are made up maybe they're true we don't
really know
um there were cynic letters or epistles
that are definitely not by the ancient
cynics but are you know
they're in their tradition
attributed to diogenes his student
crates the guy we mentioned before
anacarsus heraclitus
and then there was an emperor
julian
sometimes called julian the apostate
because the the roman emperors by then
were christian and he decided i'm not
being a christian i'm going to go back
to the ancient greek religion and do
philosophy
and he has a bunch of orations that are
about cynicism
including one to the uneducated cynics
where again
cynics who are not real cynics and he's
saying hey you dirty bums this isn't
cynicism this is what real cynicism
looks like you know so we we have a lot
of source texts and
you know there's a lot we can learn by
by reading them they are of course about
ancient
uh societies and cultures so i think we
have to do a lot of adapting work
to make them fit our modern times and
obviously there's things like the
internet or radio shows or
you know modern ways of dressing that
they
they didn't anticipate but
um
there's a lot of great stuff contained
in those works
yeah let's buy a whole summer reading
list in one go
there is a place online and i don't
remember exactly where it is where like
all of these things and more are listed
i think it's somewhere
on medium perhaps one of the modern day
cynics put it together
nice we'll see if we can track that down
now the the real question here is
what did the ancient cynics actually
believe and so we've talked about it a
lot and so the most important thing to
the cynics is
virtue once again as we talked about
just a moment ago virtue on uh
schools you have the versatilians as
well as the stoics on the stoics
as we've talked about um zeno was a
student of a cynic before he built his
own school um and so what are
what is virtue in the
cynic sense
so you know they recognize the same
general virtues you can think of these
as like um
character traits that are recognized
within ancient greek society as
important to develop in a person and
sometimes we talk about the cardinal
virtues wisdom justice
temperance and
courage that were all those are all
recognized by pretty much all of these
schools
the cynics also talked about piety which
is you know proper relation to the gods
or or to god
and then um
a term that's
in in greek is megalopsuchia so you can
translate it as great soulness but
oftentimes we call it magnanimity which
is a tough one to say correctly i've you
know practiced it recently so
to not not screw it up and it basically
means the same thing being like you know
the kind of person who's above it all
and um you know
there's different construals of what
exactly these mean but they're all
viewed as things that we need to develop
within ourselves that we don't
automatically have you know it's a lot
of times i'm going to go on a little bit
of a rant here you see people in the
present day talking about like virtue
ethics and we're going to you know teach
virtue to kids and stuff like that and
then they just give them these flash
cards that have these names on them like
wisdom and prudence and you know
generosity and stuff like that
and you know how much good that does
those kids not a damn bit yeah because
you're not telling them
what these are
you're just saying you should behave
this way and look this way and a cynic
would look at that and be like
that's garbage you know you need to to
actually give them some
education in what justice looks like you
know
and uh yeah like you were saying you
know this for the cynics virtue is
basically everything you want to be
virtuous
and if you don't have these virtues
already you got to cultivate them and
it's a lot of hard work
but there's a good payoff to it because
it makes you use that word eudaimonia
earlier um actually why don't you say
because i i'm not going to assume that
viewers have listened to or
listeners have
have heard previous things what does
eudaimonia mean so it's sometimes
translated as either happiness
or on excellence and so what what it
makes me um an excellent
individual i'm sorry um
what what is a happy life as well as
what is
um
uh
fully fulfilling human life yeah
and it's gonna go along with some other
things like freedom um
you know not being drawn into things
that
you know they would say make you a slave
um
and this is actually a good jumping off
point to talk about pleasure right
which is i know something that that you
wanted to get into
um
so think of like pleasure as this like
this line and we can like go upon this
line at different points and we can kind
of find different schools that lie along
this line of pleasure from you know
pleasure is the good to pleasure is not
the good and so at one end we have the
epicureans where you know pleasure is
the good and so they seek on the
pleasure and avoid pains this doesn't
mean specifically to be a gluttonous all
the time because if you're gluttonous
all the time then you're going to have
either going to be hung over or you're
going to be over full and these are
actually painful states or unpleasant
states and so you want to remove those
as well
but they they do consider
pleasure a good in and of itself we have
the uh aristotelianism and so some
pleasures are good um but uh
virtue is a better uh pleasure than just
you know our sensational pleasures um
and then we have our stoics which we've
spoken about in the past on where uh
pleasures are indifference and virtue is
the soul good and so once again the
cynics share this latter part of it that
virtue is the soul good but pleasure is
not a good specifically not even an
indifferent and that it can enslave
those who seek it
yeah and so
this is this is a really important thing
i would say in our time because you know
we live in a culture
i'm not going to say that we're soft but
we are constantly bombarded
with
opportunities for and
suggestions that we partake in certain
pleasures i mean if you think just about
eating right
if you were going to have a dessert in
ancient times most likely if it was
sweet it was flavored with something
like honey or figs or
something along those lines i mean
europeans complain that
things like spaghetti sauce here in the
united states are too sweet you know the
bread is too sweet because sugar's added
or corn syrup is added to so many
different things and why because you
know it makes things kind of tasty and
we have you know all sorts of other
ways in which
the drive for pleasure is constantly
catered to i mean super size it well
right with it with food but i was
thinking about like streaming content
you know it used to be like
and now you're younger than me so you
tell me if i still had a blockbuster
card well blockbuster right but when i
was a kid there you know i
there was cable it existed but we didn't
have it so you had like four or five
channels
and
you know if a show came on unless it was
like a rerun
you had to wait for the new episode to
come out and if like you had a event
that night well you missed it and then
and then the vcr came out you could like
record it
uh if somebody was there to actually
push the button and then you could have
like programmable ones and then and then
yes we get blockbuster and the capacity
to you know get movies and then you know
uh tv shows in in boxes and then we get
dvds and and then pretty soon we get
netflix and our first netflix is
actually dvds that come to your house
it's not streaming
and then we get streaming right and now
it's no longer just netflix but it's
also
hulu and you know there's all these
different streaming services and now you
can binge watch you can binge watch
things constantly you don't even have to
like hit next to watch the next episode
or the next film it's that's right yeah
offered up to you
so there's yeah so with respect to those
pleasures we're kind of spoiled right
and the thing about also like how
uh much like ac is a thing like you know
when i was a kid that wasn't at least in
my experience not a lot of people had it
that was a a
very kind of expensive nicety to have
and now it seems that we all have that
there was one kid on our block whose
parents had air conditioning
and you'd go over there and you'd be
like oh it's so cold here you know
because the rest of us we would just go
down in the basement if it got too hot
you know or we just or we just lived
with it um so anyway let's come back to
the pleasures we talked about some other
key ideas for the
cynics
one of the things that i think is really
really central is this rejection of
social conventions
and institutions and this is one way
they differ from the stoics who
are in a certain respect like the cynics
but
a bit muted a bit more toned down right
yeah they're you know there's pro-social
to the point where there's like okay if
there's something's really wrong you you
bring something up yeah for the most
part it's like okay these people are
doing i don't need to go on and directly
confront everyone because i don't think
that they are
not conforming as well as they should be
not conforming yeah the cynics
not quite so much right
so there's a number of stories of uh
diogenesis uh cynic
about him
going into the marketplace and eating
which apparently was a big faux pas that
you shouldn't be eating in the
marketplace and they're like why are you
eating i was like oh well i was hungry
why not
and other things too
yeah well you've already talked about
the one of masturbation so yeah that was
the other one yes it's very well known
he did other crazy stuff i mean he lived
in essentially a barrel that he turned
into a house and um
there's a story about when there was a
siege he's rolling the barrel back and
forth and peop people what what the hell
are you doing he's like well everyone
looked so busy i wanted to look busy
myself he's trying to he's trying to you
know give them a lesson by doing this
um and he would go up directly and like
there's a story of him like holding up a
lantern saying i'm looking for a good
man and shining and directing their eyes
are you good man that's like
you know that that is directly
confronting people about you know
what their actions are and why are they
doing the things they're doing yeah
and and so why did they do this it
wasn't just
well i mean some of them perhaps it was
just to be jerks
um
but
officially
it was to
show people that we should live a life
that's not dictated to by customs or
conventions we should live out a natural
human life we should stick to human
nature
and this required some
real
courage on their part and also what they
call shamelessness a lack of
embarrassment a lack of the sense of
shame where other people would feel this
there's actually a story
i think it's about diogenes where
somebody says he wants to be one of his
students and he gives them a big fish to
carry around through the marketplace
and the guy does it for a little bit and
he's like this is bs and he throws the
fish away and diogenes says well you
lost you know you threw away my
friendship over the price of a fish but
it was really not about the fish it was
about the social embarrassment of
looking like a like a you know like a
jerk
so
um so but this also has a number of like
benefits you know one of the the big uh
social cohesions that we
have is like what are our what's the
group that we consider ourselves part of
and so like okay
you shouldn't be even having this idea
of that like you're an athenian or you
are a um a new yorker or you are like a
i don't know someone from london london
night um
and yeah
londoner i don't know londoner
um instead you should be a member of the
the world probably the whole cosmos and
this is you know once again
cosmopolitanism
and so removing or rejecting this
ethnocentrism uh allows you to
actually be virtuous and not like make
decisions along the lines of oh what's
what is the good being you know what is
good for the people i like and and
bad things happening to people that i
don't like yeah
yeah i mean there's a real sense of
humanity that it helps to
encourage
a identification with people regardless
of the differences that they they have
with you
you know
um oh go ahead
let's just say like you know
speaking of differences and how people
have like thrown off these these old
accoutrements that they had especially
of like wealth we should talk about
karates and high
parachutes oh hipparchia yeah parky i'm
sorry about that that's that's okay so
um this is a really interesting
couple
crates was a student of dayogenes right
so he's in the lineage
and hipaakia her brother was a friend
and student of uh of krates and that's
how um they got to know each other
and
hipaakia was a very unconventional woman
she she had like you know arranged
marriages lined up because her parents
were trying to you know follow
convention and she's like nope not that
guy nope not that guy i want a guy who's
like actually into virtue and learning
and you know the important stuff in life
right so already she's kind of a weirdo
and she meets crates and she's like
that's the guy for me
and krates is like no i'm not you know
this is look at the life that i live i
don't have anything i wander around all
over the place i beg for my food
this is not what you want lady and she's
like nope that's exactly what i want and
she won't leave him alone until he
agrees to
marry her
and so in a certain way it's a this is
really fascinating it's a rejection of
traditional marriage
right and ways of living being a
householder but they're definitely still
married because they're having sex in
public
you know that that's that go ahead
it's once again that rejection of a
convention yeah or did you do that it's
like that beatles song you know should
we do it in the road you know well they
did he said these are the original road
doers
and we were pretty sure that she
actually um got pregnant and had at
least one kid from these um stoic
letters that may or may not be uh
spurious but certainly reflect
traditions about them and so what this
shows you i mean to begin with it's cool
that she's a you know a woman
philosopher who's not just like in the
proverbial ivory tower locked away she's
out there in the street with her guy
going around doing the cynic thing
doing philosophy as a way of life but
it's also kind of cool that this is part
of their tradition and it goes back to
antis one of the things that he was
claiming is both men and women can have
virtue equally you know so she's showing
at least in a cynic way that that she
can do that
yeah
so another way to reject convention is
to have very different uh ideas about
uh wealth and poverty and what these
things give you and so definitely one of
the main things is
that they see that um
these these material possessions
actually
make you a slave to them and that only
yeah through
uh poverty does one actually get you
know
uh the ability to
become totally free
yeah and this is probably a hard one for
people today especially since we live in
an economy
where
um if you don't have a certain level of
wealth and possessions
it's very difficult for you to
do things with your life right if you're
if you're a street person
getting you know oftentimes people will
walk up to them and get a job well
getting a job these days requires
having access to the internet because
you've got to apply for most of your
jobs online right
so i mean that wasn't the case back then
um you could wander around and have a
begging bowl
as as ascetics often did
not just in ancient greece but in india
and china and places like that
um and
it you know not having to worry about
the wealth that you have and how you're
going to keep it and how you're not
going to get robbed
that is um freedom
right you know like
they they say that the
embracing poverty gives one
invincibility total freedom and
self-sufficiency this also helps if
you're like in a mediterranean climate
exactly it makes things a little bit
easier in that regard um but if you're
in a warm enough climate it makes things
much easier to have a really strongly
aesthetic lifestyle i guess so that's
why you kind of see these and you know
both uh india and the mediterranean and
parts of china
yeah that would be tough to do here in
wisconsin i think you know
or you could be like if you're familiar
with tunnel bob
no
who's that
tunnel bob is a gentleman who um
lives in madison wisconsin and he um
[Music]
lives in the steam tunnels of the uw um
university
um so you just you can't get him out of
him he knows it like the back of his
hands um
you get him out and he finds his way
back in
yeah exactly okay so um he's just he's
you know like six five he's a tall guy
he's easy to pick out older gentlemen i
hope he's still alive um but you know
he's just you know he's rather benign
but he just loves the tunnels and he's i
would call him quite a bit of a a modern
day aesthetic yeah
that makes sense
um well that we should talk about
asceticism that's when we say that we
mean like a life of discipline or
hardship
and um the cynics practice this
deliberately and it wasn't just about um
poverty
it was also you know trying to live a
very simple life um
doing activities that would toughen your
body like diogenes would lay in the hot
sun and it gets pretty hot you know in
in greece uh and then in the winter he
would hug statues to toughen up his body
that way as well and this is not just
toughening up your body it's also
toughening up your mind right
yes but we're all getting rather close
to uh cold showers
yeah i mean that's a popular
thing for cynics and stoics today
i'm not a huge fan
of cold showers for their own sake or
even for asceticism
um myself because i'm i'm i don't like
cold but
uh have you did you do those or
i tried it for a second they're nicer in
the summer obviously
um it's cold enough in winter i don't
need to do it then
um
but yeah like the um
lacrates is quoted as saying philosophy
is a quarter beans and a care for
nothing um and dodge
um of snow bar dodging
is also known for like he has this story
about like
him having a bull to drink water from
the river and he sees this boy cup his
hands and go and drink from the river
and he goes
i'm being outdone by this boy and throws
away the bull um
this is very much you know his their
idea of what is it to live a good life
you'll live a good life in accordance
with nature and
nature you don't need bulls you can get
the water as well with your hands with
the bowl
yeah and you know they did have like an
outfit that they were known for a staff
a cloak and usually kind of a worn out
old smelly cloak
and what they call a wallet they
translated as that i think we would
translate as like a satchel or a pack
because you'd keep your your cheese and
your beans and stuff like that in there
and um that was it i mean that's not an
awful lot of stuff it's not five
suitcases that you somehow get on the
train or into the airplane
it's just what you've got on you at the
time
and you know i i remember times when i
would go places and you know obviously i
would have like a wallet you know that i
would keep money in and cards in things
like that but not having to care about
all this other stuff like where did i
leave my car you know um
that can be quite uh quite freeing right
right
i had a
cousin of mine who backpacked through
southeast asia oh wow with just a a a
five gallon bucket and he had a blog it
wasn't just like bucket boy so no um no
blanket no sleeping bag no
whatever you could fit into the five
gallon box
okay he carried with him yeah
so it's just like you know try to reduce
the things
that's interesting how far did he get
oh he went all over um and now he's a a
banker in london
um
oh a lovely gentleman um well you know
going back to something that you
remarked just as a segway so the the
quarter beans
now beans have a tendency as we you know
all of you know the old versions you
know beans beans the musical fruit you
know or beans beans good for the heart
and you probably know the rest of the uh
the poem so i don't need to recite it
for you
but um that was actually
not a virtue but that was a virtue of
those things in in the you know more
loose sense
because you know it would lead to
flatulence and the
cynics were you know they were they like
to laugh and they also like to this is
another way of sort of violating
conventions is like you'd go somewhere
and let one rip and then you know
everybody's not quite so serious after
that and this leads us into talking
about their um it's translated as
frankness or freedom of speech parasia
in greek right which means being able to
say whatever the hell you want to
and and this is something that was
viewed as important like you you notice
that
plato in the republic
talks about um this is one of the things
that people think democracy consists in
being not just getting to vote but
getting to like say whatever the hell
you want
but people didn't oftentimes say what
what they wanted right so
being able to
say the things that are on your mind
there's a freedom in that
but the cynics went beyond that right
yeah they
were right up in your face like you
already talked about the you know going
up and asking like you know looking for
a good man with a uh you know a lantern
in his hand
um but you know they were all about
really speaking truth to power to like
you know really cutting down those
people that thought that they were you
know the bees knees or you know or
holier than thou
however you want to put it just because
of their particular positions and saying
like
why are you actually thinking that this
thing is good i'm going to um
rip this this uh ideology or this thing
a new one
because you aren't actually thinking
through this at all yeah
and um
plato was a particular target back then
antisthenes went after him
diogenes really went after plato i mean
it was it was like he
he saw him not as the enemy but as like
the the main guy to to razz
you know they uh would sometimes call
the st the cynics um what uh
socrates gone mad right yeah well
socrates would go around and be the
gadfly and uh i guess you call the
cynics the the horde of hornets coming
around and and not just needling but
like you know making a pincushion of you
there's a lot of good one-liners in
diogenes laertes where
um
diogenes of synope the cynic would would
go after plato like plato
sees diogenes
washing vegetables
and you know what you'd have to do to
get your meal ready and plato says you
know if you'd gone and
done some homage to dionysus this this
guy who was a local ruler you wouldn't
have to be washing cabbages or whatever
it is and then diogenes says yeah and if
i if you um had washed some vegetables
you wouldn't have to go kiss the butt of
this guy you know
[Laughter]
and another time it goes uh they're
they're having the philosophers having a
conversation and i believe it's uh
uh plato that puts out this idea that um
okay um a man is a uh a
featherless biped yeah
and and
dodgy's the cynic hears this and goes
and comes back with the plucked chicken
and he goes behold a man
yes i mean that's a good way to like
show that plato didn't really
know as much as as he was pretending to
um it must have been kind of rough being
plato with those guys around
[Laughter]
but you know they they it goes beyond
just like being a jerk and
and a funny guy
um they thought that this was good for
everybody they
there's this phrase that they're heralds
of god meaning that they're like
announcing the best way to live and and
they're um
they're haranguing people so that they
can draw them to the good life
so there's there's almost like a
medicinal
um
property or function to it right and
like you said socrates was doing this
himself but he was doing it in a more
like ironic oh you know you're so smart
tell them show me how smart you are you
know right the cynics instead get up and
say hey dummy you're not so smart as you
pretend to be and you see that there's a
difference between those approaches
right and one works definitely better
for a crowd and one works better for
actually having a a good interlocutor or
someone you're actually trying to have a
dialogue with to actually like come to
change minds because most people once
you like yell at them and say like oh
you're so dumb they're not going to be
changing their mind they're going to
like harden their position against that
thing that's true yeah yeah and i i'm
sure that and we we hear about sort of
like the successes of the cynics i'm
sure there were a lot of cases where
they got the worst of things
and and we should talk briefly before we
talk about our practice about so we
started out talking about modern day
cynicism
there are people in the present who
actually are trying to live a
way of life that is faithful to the
cynics of you know 2 000 years 2 000
plus years ago
and um they have you know a facebook
group called the kuno sarges named after
the the gymnasium where the cynics uh
would supposedly meet and there's you
know uh all sorts of websites out there
it's not as big as say the modern stoic
or modern epicurean movement but it's it
exists you know
and i think that we could ask are there
other groups or types that kind of fit
in with this
maybe the the old-fashioned hippies
and other like get back to nature types
are kind of like the cynics
but kind of not like them you know
but we could also say
and i'm kind of curious to see what you
think about this dan
what about um what people these days
call minimalism you know where you try
to reduce your possessions and
uncomplicate your life but within a
modern framework
does that i mean it doesn't have the
like i'm going to go out and harangue
people
aspect to it
and it doesn't necessarily tie in with
virtue but i mean do you see that as
similar to cynicism
i think it has some of the the trappings
thereof okay but like there's
you don't have anything about virtue you
don't have anything about going back to
nature because most of these people live
in like apartments with like very few
things yeah and part of it is you live
in an apartment so you don't have to
have like a yard to deal with and
whatnot right this requirement there's a
certain amount of things that other
people are doing for you this requires
that um so i guess
like
it's if you want to call it like kind of
close in a modern-day sense of things
like under what our system allows
maybe but i don't know yeah i'm not i'm
not fully there no
yeah i kind of think you're right that
there are some
so there it's like a venn diagram where
there's some overlap but there's some
stuff that's not there
so um you want to lead us into the
practice
a very simple practice
um i hope i won't be too cynical i'm
talking about it so um rejecting
convention so we talked about this is
one of the main things that um the
cynics tried to do in order to try to
get back to actual nature and so the
cynics openly and intentionally walked a
contrarian path the reason was twofold
first to try to adjust their own mindset
away from following convention and
secondly to force others to confront the
reasons they themselves conform to that
mindset so we can go and do something
you know contrarian so um i don't know
you know we can walk backwards down the
street i'm thinking now of like um the
ministry of silly walks oh yeah yeah uh
monty python that would be another way
to wear like a onesie pajamas um in the
mall
on anything that will break up the right
way of doing anything see any of that
come off your mind greg
well um
well first of all picturing the onesies
you know there was always uh is it truly
a onesies or does it also have like the
back flap thing
leave that open right
oh you're
yeah there's i mean there's all sorts of
things you could do i was just thinking
there's so many things where we
we've gotten used to doing them this way
and this is just the way it is and we
expect people to do things that way
and we might also be a little bit afraid
of like um social
ostracism social criticism
or getting filmed or something like that
maybe actually like filming yourself
doing something like that could be
an add-on to it
you know the question is though
i was actually thinking about this that
if you're doing it to film to put out
for social media now why are you doing
this are you doing this to try to break
your social convention are you just
doing this to get views right so the
intention would be required
to be scrutinized as well yeah and i
think both of the ones that you brought
up could work right it could be to try
to get get yourself out of that groove
that you're in
but also to show others that we don't
have to do things this this way
so yeah but now we do have one book
recommendation because we're getting
close to the the end
um for you and it's a contemporary book
very short one but it's really quite
good uh and scar allen's recent i think
it's 2020 book just called cynicism and
we'll add a link to a book review video
about it that i did a while back
um do you want to lead us out on a uh
final quote then or yeah so we leave you
today with the words of anticipates
wisdom is a most sure stronghold which
never crumbles away nor is betrayed
walls of defense must be constructed in
our own impregnable reasonings
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you